How important is the grounding that in conjunction with the rife treatments?
So the grounding that comes with your rife machine is to be used,
when you use the iron pro wave. So iron pro wave, everybody thinks it's just to pull
junk out of your body through your feet. No, it's to get different frequencies in your body and
doing so it does have an avenue of escape for different things as well. So but the purpose of that
is to pull the frequencies into your body and you do want to put the grounding mat behind your
back when you're doing iron pro wave. That's only time you're used to the grounding mat. If you have
a different grounding mat at home or a grounding sheet at home, as I have said in so many of the
videos, the grounding sheet should be used on the lower half of your bed underneath the fitted
mattress, fitted sheet, the lower half of your bed underneath the fitted sheet.